how have you found your voice as an
artist
I've just written stories that I want to
write I've never
tried to
write something that I don't want to
write and and I'll explain that in a way
that I've been pitched certain books or
IP and and at first it'll be exciting
but then I'm like I'm not I don't care
about this I don't care about this
subject I don't care about this uh world
so then I don't do it so I don't do
anything that I don't want to do and
most of the time I'm excited about my
original stories and and I'll get an
idea whether I'm inspired by a moment in
my life or
I'm inspired by a song or I'm inspired
by a hike that I went on those are the
things that excite me and and keep me
going from from the seat of the idea to
writing the outline to writing the
entire script if I'm not excited about
that seed of the idea then I can't keep
moving forward in order to finish that
script which is what I always want to do
like I said I always want to have a
finished product I have a ton of friends
who start scripts and then never finish
them or like I said they start short
films and never finish them but I think
the most important thing to do
especially with the first draft of
writing a script is just finishing it
the first draft is what I always call a
vomit draft and it's never any good but
guess what it's 90 pages long great I've
reached my goal of 90 Pages now the hard
work is rewrite getting the first draft
so then I rewrite it and and I get it to
a place where I think it's
okay to be seen by the four or five
people that I trust to give me good
critical notes on my scripts and then
and then I get those notes and then I
continue to rewrite continue to rewrite
but for me it's always about getting
that page count to 90 Pages especially
with the first draft and then proceeding
with the rewrites from there
that's interesting do you think the math
science part of your brain has really
trained you to make sure that you finish
things that that there's a that it all
works out yeah yeah I really do and it's
so strange because that because that
didn't click until a few years ago where
where I'm really structured about
writing scripts and I'm like okay I'm
gonna write 10 pages this week and then
10 pages next week and I write it down
in my planner and I cross it off once
I'm done and I get to 20 40 60 80. and
and and that really excites me and so
um I I remember one thing from all of my
engineering years I walked into my first
class
in college and the teacher wrote out
engineer equals problem solver and I
said huh I said I am a problem solver
and and I use that in all of my work I
use that in my screenwriting I'm like
okay well how do I get this character
out of this situation okay how do I how
do I finish this script how do I what's
if I've already written the end how do I
get there what are these middle scenes
in between
um even with uh being on set of
definition please I kept thinking about
engineer equals Problem Solver and I was
like okay we've lost this location how
am I gonna problem solve
getting a location without freaking out
my cast and crew in the meantime and so
I do believe uh
uh my training as an engineer and in
math and science has truly helped my
artwork because even in
um I mentioned that I also write poems
and I write songs and I had written
poems and then I got together with my
friend will Collier who composes our
music
and he taught me the basic structure of
a song and I could take that structure
and I'm like oh great I can definitely
follow this formula to write this song
So once again that was my math mind
writing an artistic song
I love that if you were to be the
teacher at a screenwriting course or
filmmaking and you wrote screenwriter
equals
we actually have a chalkboard here but
screenwriting equals and what would be
the other word on the end of the equal
sign
I'm gonna say Problem Solver okay
screenwriter equals problems okay
because you're always solving problems
you're you're coming up with the premise
and you're always putting your
characters into problematic situations
that they have to get out of and only
you can take them out of those
situations and and that's part of what's
exciting you let the characters guide
you into their own stories and and you
are now solving their problems okay and
then actor equals
Entertainer okay
and last but not least filmmaker equals
visionary
I like it how do you know what you're
creating is coming from your unique
voice
what I'm excited about it so
something that was really fun for me on
definition please is that when we
started shooting
I the day before we started day one of
shooting it felt like the way you feel
before the first day of school
and
I was really excited and I couldn't
really get to sleep but I knew that I
had to sleep and
that's when you know that's when you
know you're doing what you're supposed
to be doing and you're telling a story
that's unique to you and your point of
view when you're in that moment and
he just can't wait to wake up in the
morning and and get to work and
tell the story that you've been living
with for
a few years and that that's what's
exciting to me when I can
be excited about rewriting a script that
that I had uh poured my unique voice
into and and and you know
be able to change that or adjust it and
make it a better story and and I just
get excited like I said during the
during the pandemic when I was
um pushing out all these scripts it was
just a joy to sit at my laptop and get
back into these lives of the characters
that I had created and in each one of
those characters had their own unique
voice which wasn't necessarily mine so
it was exciting to take on those roles
as well
you say you don't take something on
unless it excites you so you already
know once you've taken something on you
know that you're committed to it you're
not going to you know because some
people might be persuaded oh yeah all
right I'll do it I'll do it but it
sounds like you already know you have a
real definition inside of you that you
know this is something I'm going to
stick with
I have no problem saying no to things so
I have walked away from a lot of big
projects and ideas that may have
made me a lot of money but that I wasn't
necessarily excited about so that that's
number one I listen to my voice I listen
to how I feel when I'm reading something
or being pitched something and so I I
suppose I have the Marie condo
philosophy of oh is this going to bring
me joy and generally if it's my original
idea yes and then I continue on with
that but if it's someone else's idea
then I really have to think about it and
say okay is this going to bring me joy
or am I going to get stressed out and
and I'm not someone who gets stressed
out ever so
so those are my two questions that I ask
myself in terms of taking on a role or
taking on someone else's work in terms
of writing or directing it
so have you ever rethought something
that you turned down and thought no oh
no you were very clear on it yeah very
clear very clear on it I
I don't regret anything in my life and
you know a lot of people would say oh
well don't you regret going to
engineering school instead of going to
acting school or and getting an Arts
education and and like you mentioned I
use my engineering and my math and
science background to
uh create my scripts to create my
stories and they have gone hand in hand
which is really exciting so I've I've
never regretted anything any decisions
that I've made in the past
what compels you to write
different things different ideas
I'm always inspired by
experiences so I think it's really
important for
writers to go out and experience life
and not just be sitting in their room
all day and writing so you know
something that I really loved from my
upright citizen Brigade improv and
sketch classes one of the assignments
that a teacher had given us was
go out and do
something new this week something that
you wouldn't necessarily do
try something new so I think during that
class I I ate insects for the first time
which I didn't really love I I think I
watched like an old action movie I'm not
really into action movie so I just kind
of watched that and and it was great
because you have to expand your mind you
have to learn about different things and
and those things will inspire you so
whether it's a character who's really
into action movies whether it's it's a
scene at a restaurant where they're only
serving insects whether it's so I those
different experiences will inspire
something and strike a match in your
brain for maybe not a project that
you're currently working on but maybe
something in the future and so so I
continue to do that even after taking
the class I continue to
read something that I wouldn't normally
read or or try a new food that I that I
wouldn't normally try and that's that's
what's exciting to me just new
experiences I believe inspire me all the
time
how do you create a meaningful story
think as long as you're telling the
story from your heart then other people
will gravitate towards it so
I wanted to tell a story about a
specific type of family that went
through Universal problems and
and I wasn't sure what an audience was
gonna think about it and and I really
made it for myself and I made it for my
friends and family because I knew that
they would enjoy it and then all of a
sudden different audiences were
pulled towards it and really enjoying
the film and that was that was kind of a
surprise to me but but it's exciting to
to find out that your story that you put
a lot of heart into is also emotionally
affecting other people as well
did people come up to you after
screenings I mean we didn't have a lot
of screenings because of covid oh so
these stuff so so it was more through
um tweeting at me or direct messaging me
or through emails where I was learning
that
these uh these people these audience
members who had watched the movie really
enjoyed it and really
felt connected to it and felt something
they felt seen we talked about making
sure you only do projects that you feel
compelled to do that you don't want to
do something you don't want to go to
something you don't want to be at
what's your thought on creating a story
that's emotional versus one that's more
commercial
I like them both I'm trying to create
both stores I think it's possible to
create
a commercial story with emotion and
heart and I think that's that's the
beauty of
making a big budget film and you can
sneak heart in there
but but show it to a wider audience and
that's exciting to me I think I I love
comedy so I'm gonna
stick to comedic stories but even within
that comedy I believe there's gotta be
hard no matter what budget you're making
the project for and yeah I have ideas
that are very commercial and I'm looking
at it for my own specific unique point
of view and and I haven't seen
necessarily those stories
commercially out there yet so it's
exciting to also create for a bigger
budget
so you don't think there's commercial
stories that have some type of a meaning
maybe just a few out there I think there
are definitely commercial stories that
have that have heart and meaning and I
think even more so today since studios
are only making five or six movies a
year they have to find a way to make
sure that these audiences coming in
relate to these characters on a certain
level and and are rooting for them and
so that I mean for example I just
watched a film and I don't know if you
would call it big budget but Barb and
star go to Vista Del Mar and I thought
it was so funny so absurdly comedic but
there is a story there about female
friendships and and and I just love that
and it it is a you know bigger budget
film with with stars and and so that
that's the kind of work that I'd love to
make at some point sure was that an a24
movie that was a Lionsgate oh okay all
right I thought I've seen trailers for
it and I I looked cute I was like okay I
would watch it it's great I loved it